somebody did a look at our entries on on
novelists who've won a major literary
prize and they looked at the male
novelist versus the female and the male
novelist had longer and higher quality
entries and why is that well it's not
because because I know
hundreds of wikipedians it's not because
these are a bunch of
biased sexist men who are like books by
women are not important it's like no
actually there is a uh a gender kind of
breakdown of readership there are books
like hard science fiction is a classic
example hard science fiction mostly read
by men other types of novels more read
by women and if we don't have women in
the community then these award-winning
clearly important novelists may have
less coverage and not because anybody
consciously thinks uh we don't like what
a book by Maya Angelou like who cares
she's a poet like that's not interesting
no but just because well people write
what they know they write what they're
interested in so we do think diversity
in the community is really important and
that's one area where I do think it's
really clear but I can also say you know
what actually that also applies in the
political sphere like to say actually we
do want kind and thoughtful uh Catholic
priests kind and thoughtful
conservatives kind and thoughtful
Libertarians kind and thoughtful
marxists you know to come in but the key
is the kind and thoughtful piece so when
people sometimes come to Wikipedia
outraged by some
you know dramatic thing that's happened
on Twitter they come to Wikipedia with a
chip on their shoulder ready to do
battle and it just doesn't work out very
well you know and there's tribes in
general where I think there's a
responsibility on the larger group to be
even Kinder and more welcoming to the
smaller group yeah we think that's
really important and so you know
oftentimes uh people come in and you
know there's a lot when I talk about
Community Health one of the aspects of
that that we do think about a lot I
think about a lot is
not about politics it's just like how
are we treating newcomers to the
community and so I can tell you what our
ideals are what our philosophy is
um but do we live up to that so you know
the ideal is you come to Wikipedia you
know we have uh rules like one of our
fundamental rules is ignore all rules
which is partly written that way because
it piques people's attention like what
what the hell kind of rule is that you
know but basically says look don't get
nervous and depressed about a bunch of
you know what's the formatting of your
footnote right so you shouldn't come to
Wikipedia add a link and then get banned
or yelled at because it's not the right
format
uh instead somebody should go oh hey
yeah thanks for for helping but you know
here's the link to how to format uh you
know if you want to keep going you might
want to learn how to format a footnote
um and and to be friendly and to be open
and to say oh right oh you're new and
you clearly don't know everything about
Wikipedia and you know sometimes in any
community that can be quite hard so
people come in and they've got a great
big idea and they're going to propose
this to the Wikipedia community and they
have no idea that's basically a
perennial discussion we've had seven
thousand times before
and so then ideally you would say to the
person oh yeah great thanks like a lot
of people have and here's where we got
to and here's the nuanced conversation
we've had about that in the past that I
think you'll find interesting and
sometimes people are just like oh God
another one you know who's come in with
this idea which doesn't work and they
don't understand why I can lose patience
but you shouldn't and that's kind of
human you know but I think it just does
require really thinking you know uh in a
in a
self-aware manner of like oh I was once
a newbie actually we do have we have a
great I just did an interview with the
uh Emily Temple Woods who she was
Wikipedia of the year she's just like a
great well-known wikipedian and I
interviewed her for my book and she told
me something I never knew apparently
it's not secret like she didn't reveal
it to me but is that when she started at
Wikipedia she was a vandal she came in
and vandalized Wikipedia and then
basically what happened was she'd done
some sort of uh vandalized a couple of
Articles and then somebody popped up on
a talk page and said hey like why are
you doing this like we're trying to make
an encyclopedia here and this wasn't
very kind yeah and she felt so bad
she's like oh right I didn't really
think of it that way she just was coming
in as she was like 13 years old
combative and you know like having fun
and trolling a bit and then she's like
oh actually oh I see your point and
became a great wikipedian so that's the
ideal really is that you don't just go
throw a block [__] off yeah you go hey
you know like what what goes you know
which is I think the way
we tend to treat things in real life you
know if you've got somebody who's doing
something obnoxious in your friend group
you'd probably go hey like really
I I don't know if you've noticed but I
think this person is actually quite hurt
that you keep making that joke about
them and then they usually go oh you
know what I didn't I thought that was
okay I didn't and then they stop or they
keep it up and then everybody goes well
you're the [__]
well yeah I mean that's just an example
that gives me Faith in humanity that uh
that we're all capable and
um wanting to be kind to each other and
in general this the fact that there's a
small group of volunteers
they're able to contribute so much to
the organization The Collection uh the
uh the discussion of all of human
knowledge is so it makes me so grateful
to be a part of this whole human project
I that's one of the reasons I love
Wikipedia is gives me Faith in humanity
no I I once was
um
at uh wikimaney is our annual conference
and people come from all around the
world like really active volunteers
I was at the dinner we were in Egypt at
wikimania in Alexandria at the sort of
closing dinner or whatever and a friend
of mine came and sat at the table and
she's sort of been in the movement more
broadly Creative Commons she's not
really a Wikipedia she'd come to the
conference because she's into Creative
Commons and all that
so we have dinner and it just turned out
I sat down at the table with most of the
members of the English language
arbitration committee and they're a
bunch of very sweet
geeky wikipedians and as we left the
table I said to her it's really like I I
still find this kind of sense of
Amazement like we just had dinner with
some of the most powerful people in
English language media because they're
the people who are like the final court
of appeal in English Wikipedia and thank
goodness they're not medium Moguls right
they're just a bunch of Geeks Who are
just like well liked in the community
because they're kind and they're
thoughtful and they really you know sort
of think about things I was like this is
great love Wikipedia